欢迎各位说今天这期摆设圈说我是三刀。
有些听友加了私喻社群的可能以为今天不更新了，其实原本也是准备不更新的，因为隔壁的友台遇到的一点小情况。
就节目最近这两期，也就是今天的周六和下个星期三，我原本就是想那友台都跟不了了嘛。
那这个台咱们就先也不跟了。
但是后来我想了想这为什么不跟呢？
对不对？
很多的听友说三刀的节目你不更新，我跑步没得听，你不更新，我这睡觉没人。
没人去伴睡，对吧？
你就睡觉不抱着老婆，你更听我这一句，就打老爷们。
小宇宙这边大家有很多新粉丝，可能也不知道什么情况，所以我说还是更新吧。
那么我想了想，就是这两天因为我其实就两个主平台嘛，一个西马拉雅，一个小宇宙。
那么最近这两期呢，也就这一期和下周三，我就做一些留言互动。
把我们的知识星球包括其他一些平台上的很有意思的一些问题，跟车买车相关的一些问题。
把它汇总一下，就做一期节目，回答大家的问题。
所以今天我挑了大概四五个问题，在今天节目里面去跟大家来聊一聊。
那么下期也是一样的，如果你有什么选车买车卖车，或者是跟什么汽车的用车相关的问题点，
都可以在评论区下方去留言。
而且还有个好处是什么呢？
就是这一期和下个星期三的这一期，相当于是只抽小宇宙的三位听友。
就我们只在小宇宙的评论区抽，因为西马拉雅没得跟了，这怎么办呢？
对不对？她上线不了节目，那么就只在小宇宙去更新。
所以中奖率还是比较高的。
当然了，看大家的心情了，你要想留言支持我一下，那么就留言去支持一下。
其实说实话，不要去讨论我为什么被封，或者为什么节目上不了价。
反正我做播客13年，我也是第一次遇到这个情况。
你想想看，我从13年到现在26年，我从一个32岁的小伙子变成40多岁的大叔，
我也不知道我到底遇到什么事情了，大家不要猜，评论区不要聊，好不好？
那肯定是有事嘛，对吧？那具体什么事？
我们就改过自新，统一思想，我们就自我升级一下意识形态，
今后我们就好好聊车，其实我觉得作为一个正能量的主播，
其实我觉得我已经很正能量了，我三观各方面都很正了，
那就到这个事儿了，只能说，可能我在某些方面做的还是不足，
我们还是要继续的加油努力。
好，我们来看一看，上期节目的，我们在知识星球上有几位听友的留言。
他的问题，第一位叫做郭克俊，他说，
刀哥，我想问一下，家里有两台车，
要不要把其中一台大概价值6万块钱的游车换成电车，不想额外去加钱。
新车推荐什么样的车型，适合女生开，用来上下班带步，
每天的往返通行大概在14公里左右，那如果是二手的话，有哪些选择，谢谢。
那么其实经常看到这样的留言，就是想把手上的游车卖掉，
然后不想加钱，直接去换一辆电车，
其实你这样子换的话，很简单，你相当于体验降级了，
为什么这么讲呢？你原来这样的游车，你是残值6万，
相当于你以前买的时候，应该是十几万的车，
那么十几万的车，你现在直接变成拿6万块钱去买一辆电车，
那一定是一个A0级的小车，你比方说像什么吉利的新院，
比亚迪的海欧，那很多了，你要想清楚，
就是你整个车辆降级的话，它的体验肯定是会降级的，
你要说有什么大屏，有什么电车的体验，
你觉得那个好，那个OK，那是没有问题的，
但是我想告诉你，整个车从底盘质感，价值感收割方面，一定百分之百是降级的，
那么很多人为什么会有这种游车换掉变电车的想法呢？
其实说到底，第一个，就是这个游车它在手头上应该是开了很多年，
没有什么新鲜感了，那么比电车来讲的话，配置肯定也低了，
车子也老了，很多地方该修，该换，也要花钱了，
那么每一次去保养，哪怕就是换一个小配件，
你可能都觉得这是沉默成本，就是在这个车上花一分钱，你都觉得意义不大，
你不想在这个车上花钱，那么再加上现在油价也是天天在涨，
对吧，所以你怎么看这个游车怎么样就不顺眼，
那么再看一看市面上这些电车呢，我刚刚前面讲的6万左右，
吉林银河比亚地还有很多，还有包括像明爵的MG4，
吉湖T1，武林兵国，像兵国S，对吧，一个一个看起来都还不错，
虽然说这些车看上去都是A0级的小车，
但是因为它是电车，所以它内部的空间其实也不小，
看着也还行，还有大屏，用电池们也低，保养也便宜，
那么到底要不要换呢，要不要换我觉得是两方面，
第一个是驾乘的体验，第二个就是算一本经济掌，
那么首先我来算一算经济掌，你现在这个游车是残值6万，
对吧，是个游车，我不知道具体的品牌跟型号，
你只要不是非常冷门的车，因为我自己也坐20个车的，
我相信你这个车今后每一年它的评估的残值，
大概要再往下降个5000块钱左右，
每一年相当于就是你的用车成本，大概是花在5000块钱左右，
就今年6万，明年5万5，那么再往后的话，
每一年基本上也就是几千块钱，
三四千块钱，五千块钱大概上下，
也就是到了后年基本上就卖个5万上下，
那么如果说你事实上风田的卡罗拉，
风田的雷铃这种，就是比较强手的，
这种日系的二手车的话，那你不仅出手快，
你有可能这个残值的这个贬损贬值，
还要再低一点，还要再低一点，
那么如果说你现在把手上这个游车卖掉，
我们假设你手上就是一辆卡罗拉，
你现在卖出去6万块钱，
那么你现在换了一辆六七万的电车，
相当于比方说我们假设的是银河，
机力银河，那么起步售价6万8800，
6万8800它因为有厂家补贴，有国补嘛，
大概能补个8000块钱，那么6800，
你还要再交个购注税，
现在是购注税减半嘛，
我们就算3000块钱吧，
对吧，6364，你还要买个保险啊，
你新车要买保险，
这个新车保险不便宜啊，
而且我告诉你，
电车保险真的都不便宜，
后面续保，
每一年的保险的费用肯定是比你游车要贵的，
你再买个保险，
你这个车其实落地七七八八算下来的话，
差不多7万块钱，
就超出了你6万预算一点点，
我觉得你加1万应该问题也不大，
对吧，7万块钱，
好，7万块钱，
相当于是游车卖了，
换了个电车，
那么这个电车呢，
你的成本是多少呢，
我这么跟你讲啊，
这台车你是7万块钱落地的，
对吧，你明年卖，
你甭管交眉交购之税，
买卖卖保险，
明年卖这个车子其实就5万多块钱，
就5万多块钱，
相当于你第一年就亏了差不多，
1万多接近2万，
好，那么你第二年再卖的话，
那么相当于是4万5上下，
等于又亏了差不多，
大几千块钱1万吧，
那么到了第三年之后，
差不多4万，
就是折损大概5千块钱，
那么再往后每一年的，
这个折损大概也就是，
小几千几千块钱，
那有人讲说，
哎，其实也还好嘛，
就越往后开，
它的这个贬值率就越低嘛，
对吧，好，
逻辑呢，
那么个逻辑，
但是这里面还有几个，
就是你只有坐过二车车的人，
你才能知道的优点和缺点，
或者说优势跟劣势吧，
那么首先，
小电车，
在二车市场上，
它的优势是什么呢，
是总价低，
所以呢，
就买车的人，
他这个心态，
或者说是他的整体的，
这个支付的意愿是比较高，
心态比较轻松，
而且呢，
这种小电车，
它的升级换代比较慢，
它不像那种
二三十万，
三四十万的电车，
就几乎是，
就是半年换一次，
一年一改款，
那各种各样的，
这些什么质价的，
算力啊，
或者是车机的芯片啊，
这各种更换，
所以你一般情况下，
不会看到说，
小电车的车主，
说我被收割了，
我沉韭菜了，
一般都是那种，
二三十万，
三四十万的电车车主，
他们说，
我沉韭菜了，是不是，
所以小电车，
升级换代比较慢，
那么它没有什么先进的，
至仓跟质价，
所以一般情况下，
二手的行情呢，
相对比较稳，
所以二手的，
这种买家一般指认，
大品牌，
你比方说，
像吉利啊，
吉利新院啊，
还有像比亚地亚，
海鸥,
这两款车，
是在二手市场最受欢迎的，
因此它的流通力比较高，
二手车确实，
我们收呢，
也敢收，
价格高一点去收，
那么卖呢，
其实略高一点卖，
也有人要，
这就是大概的一个，
行情,
也是一个比较好的，
就相当于是优势的点，
是什么呢，
就是这种小车，
你开到三年以上之后，
你就是越往后，
越难卖，
邏輯也很简单，
首先,
这种小车子，
本身它的续航，
就比较的短，
对不对，
CRTC310公里,。
因为我刚刚讲了嘛，
你其实就六七万的预算，
你就算买这种小车子，
你也只能买到一个入门卖，
对不对，
新医院的310的这个入门卖，
310入门卖，
还有六万八，
就是各种补贴算下来，
其实,
也就是六万出头，
加个税，
再买个保险，
七万块钱嘛，
那么你要想310公里的版本，
嗯,
正常用的话，
我们就算打个汽车，
打个八折，
你也就两百多公里嘛，
是不是，
那么到了冬天，
你要再开个暖气，
那这个续航数就更短，
跑高速就更不用说了嘛，
你跑长途，
速度一上来之后，
续航也会变短，
那么这台车子，
三年以后，
它的公里数，
如果再有个，
你正常家用的话，
一万多一年嘛，
就五六万公里，
甚至更多，
那么越往后，
二手车的买家，
就越不敢买，
你想啊，
这个小车，
六万公里，
七万公里，
你觉得说，
哪个人能接受，
你要说，
开到十万公里以上，
那基本上，
这车就非常难卖了，
除非是价格已经是，
就是低到让，
对方已经无法，
无法拒绝，
就低到这种程度，
你想想看，
你愿意吗，
你去买个新院，
买个,
这个海鸥，
六七万公里，
可能它能接受，
你不知道它的电池，
衰减有多少，
买回去之后，
它的真实续航有多少，
因为你CRTC才三百一啊，
是不是，
你不可能三年之后，
电池不衰减吗，
那你要如果再开个空调，
对不对，跑个高速，
那你要只能开一百多公里，
那这个车子跟，
家里的电动自行车有什么区别，
对吧,
电动自行车，
你要换个大链池，
你可能还能开个八九十公里呢，
是不是，
所以这就是，
它最大的一个难点，
在二车市场上，
你要如果是，
还相比好卖一点，
三百一十公里序号版本，
确实非常难买，
特别是三年以后，
如果说没有加充装，
那它就得要，
频繁的在外面去充电，
而且频繁的充电，
反而会加速，
这个电池的衰减，
那么就剩下来，
另外一个问题就是，
万一,
要是这个电池坏了，
你车子也过保了，
你要知道，
买这种，
小几万块钱车的人，
它是绝对不能承担，
这种,
将来维修成本那么高的，
它一个时间占用成本很高，
要经常去充电，
第二个，万一电池坏了，
它的维修成本也是巨高，
所以它就成了一个背锅的，
一个接盘侠，
所以没有人会愿意买，
所以将来不是说，
价格便不便宜的问题，
是能不能卖得出去的问题，
那么另外一点，
你要考虑到，
三年以上的二手的小电车，
每一年的差价不大，
我刚刚前面说了什么，
三年之后，
它每一年的贬值，
基本上就是几千块钱，
小几千块钱，
对，从你用车的人来讲说，
你看我的车子，
你看越往后用，
在二手市场上，
这是个悖论，
我为什么说是悖论呢，
就是你觉得它的贬值率低，
但是在二手市场上，
你想,
你同样，
四年五年六年的，
这些小电车，
比方说这个极低信任，
五年的跟四年的，
差大概三四千块钱，
你说,
四年的那个比方叫，
四万五千公里，
五年的那个六万五千公里，
我请问，
差三千块钱你买哪个？
你百分之百是买四年，
不买五年的吗？
你百分之百是买那个。
四万多公里，
不买那个五万多六万公里的吗？
想都不用想，
闭着眼睛想都知道，
我宁愿就是那个车的颜色差一点，
或者说，
可能座椅，
什么质感啊，
里面保养的差一点，
那我也要买那个公里书少的，
只要两台车子，
车矿基本一致，
就没出过事故，
正常保养，
我讲,
有没有道理？
是不是这么概念？
所以你越往后，
它的中间的差价越小，
那么买车的人，
就更愿意去接受那种，
车龄更小更短，
然后公里书更少的车型，
那为什么要买你呢？
而且你想想看，
心愿一年卖几十万辆，
大几十万辆，
像这种车型，
在二车市场上，
410的版本，
也是遍地都是，
410公里的版本的价格，
如果跟你310公里差不多，
我请问我，
为什么要买你310公里，
版本的二手车？
我为什么不去买410公里？
所以大部分的情况，
就是410公里版本的车，
先出货，
等到出的差不多了，
可能有几个，
确确实实手上，
预算非常非常的少，
捉金见肘的，
他可能会去，
考虑这个310公里版本的，
这个二手车车型，
所以你要二手车，
挂得越低，
你310公里才能卖得出去，
但是410公里，
可以按照正常的行情，
把它卖得出去，
所以好，
我们再回到你，
刚刚起面提到的，
要不要卖掉油车，
然后有个6万块钱左右，
再去换电车这个事，
你现在油车不卖，
三年后，
你的车辆的残值，
就相当于，
每一年的使用成本，
加在一起，
三年一共的，
使用成本，
也就是一万出头，
对不对，
但是你如果卖掉油车，
你三年后，
整个车辆的残值，
每一年每一年的折就，
那将近是三万，
那么你想一万和三万，
你中间差了多少钱，
差了将近两万块钱，
那么这两万块钱，
有没有帮你省下来呢，
你说,
这两万块钱是隐形的成本，
那我现在每一年，
我油钱我省下来了，
对不对，
你油钱是省了，
可是保险，
电车保险不便宜，
你这个电车的保险，
一定是比油车贵，
你不信你可以去问一下，
吉利新月，
你问他，
你说第一年保险多少钱，
第二年，第三年，
正常是多少钱，
你打电话，
你就打那个人保，
或者平安的电话，
你就告诉他，
我是吉利新月，
你帮我估个价，
我不但要估第一年，
第一年的，
我还要估明年第二年，
如果我不出钱，
你再去算一算，
你这台车子，
现在六万块钱，
这个油车，
你的保险是多少钱，
你中间如果我，
猜的没有错，
你估计能差一两千，
可能都不止，
好，那么我们，
我们再讲一讲，
你一两万，
你去,
每一天用电车，
是能省油钱的，
但是你一天，
开多少公里呢，
你往返十四公里，
往返十四公里，
三百六十五天，
你乘一下不就出来了吗，
你一年就开五千公里，
五千公里，
我给你翻一倍可以吧，
你一年开一万公里，
一万公里，
你一公里的油车，
我就算是六毛钱，
差不多吧，
八个油左右嘛，
现在应该是八块多吧，
九块吗，
反正不管怎么说吧，
八九个油，
你不可能那么高吧，
你一个六万块钱，
我就算六毛钱一公里，
那么你开电车，
这里就有一个问题点了，
你有没有四人充电桩，
你如果有四人充电桩，
你有固定车位，
那你就很神了，
但是如果你没有四人充电桩，
你在外面充电，
现在外面的电价都在涨，
都在涨，
所以我就算啊来平均吧，
就算你一公里两毛钱，
你一公里两毛钱，
油车一公里六毛钱，
我们就毛咕咕嘛，
你一公里省四毛，
一年一万公里省四千块钱，
三年省一万二，
我们刚刚前面讲的，
你车辆在贬损这一块，
三年你电车比油车，
引擎的成本要多付出大概两万块钱，
你现在这个等于说油钱，
三年一共才省了一万二，
那么一阵一反，
你要知道，
电车你是用下来感觉省，
但是实际上它并不省，
从它的整个的，
如果以三年的使用寿命的，
使用周期来讲，
生命周期来讲的话，
那其实你根本就没省到什么钱，
甚至开电车反而成本更高，
那么你说，
那到底要不要换电车呢，
电车有几点，
我觉得是油车比不了的，
那么首先就是驾驶体验，
确实会好很多，
而且你比较说，
你出去吃个饭，
你现在开个电车，
你也愿意跑远一点了，
但是你要用个油车，
你可能觉得说，
油钱跟吃饭的钱也差不多了，
是不是，
而且还有一点，
电车,
你平时在车子里面，
出去空调，
对不对，
你有时候等孩子，
在车里面玩玩手机，
休息一会，
那么不管是从安全性，
还是舒适的感觉来讲，
其实都会好很多，
因为马上都夏天了，
夏天的话，
你一直原地开空调，
你这个耗电，
其实跟耗油，
感受是完全不一样的，
你那边油车，
不仅仅是耗油，
你的发动机，
轰轰轰的响，
你电车开个空调，
小风吹吹，
没有发动机，
车里面很安静，
稍微休息一会，
不管是安全性，
还是舒适度，
确实有差别，
你要如果完全是考虑到，
从使用的角度来讲的话，
可以换，
没有任何的问题，
因为你家里面，
电车跑不了长途，
你另外一辆车，
可以跑长途吗，
但你要如果说，
从成本角度来讲，
从便利性上来讲，
你这台车子，
牺牲的是什么，
第一个，跑长途，
你基本上就不用想了，
对吧，那续航就在那边摆着呢，
是不是，
第二个呢，
它不像加油那么方便，
加油一加完，
你就想跑多少跑多少跑多少，
跑多远都可以，
那电车就只能是，
是去带个步，
因为你就是个
300多公里，
续航的电车嘛，
对不对，
其实我觉得都差不多，
除非你那个油车，
已经是，
经常要坏了，
如果不是经常坏，
你比方说像我讲的卡罗拉，
你保养也没多少钱成本啊，
现在的电车保养一次，
也差不多300上下，
200多300块钱，
你卡罗拉的话，
你其实出去换个，
什么机油机率，
也差不多就200多块钱啊，
你也不可能去CSS电了嘛，
你就在旁边的修理上，
什么土壶养车，
天猫养车的，
就很便宜，
所以我觉得他们保养成本，
没有差别多少，
但是保险的成本，
一定是电车比油车要高很多，
然后摄像来就是体验，
所以你想明白这几点，
我说的也很清楚了，
对吧，很详细了，
换和不换，
我觉得你想明白你就，
很明确了，
是吧,
所以我也不是说，
建议你换或者不换，
就看你的需求，
需求很重要，
好，我们再看看，
夏业尾听友，
所以说我们老听友了，
他叫陆飞，
海贼王陆飞是吧，
他说,
刀哥,
我的亲戚今年55岁，
刚退休，
去年花一万多块钱，
一对一的驾校，
这么贵吗，
我前两天还听到一个朋友的孩子，
也是一对一，
而且这个驾校上门接送，
也才五千多块钱，
你这一对一跑家照，
怎么这么贵，
你哪个城市上，
哪个城市这么贵，
他说,
他平时呢，
会拿他亲戚的车子，
去练一练手，
也练了有一年了，
那么现在呢，
想自己去买一台SUV，
平时在四川的小县城，
和村子里面去逮捕，
出门玩呢，
也很方便，
那么他现在看重两款车，
一个是大众的图月，
新锐，锐进版，
还有一个是杰达的VS5，
自动先锋版，
他说,
每一天他还在看直播，
去做功课，
连什么空腔住辣，
爱情变速箱，
这些他都知道了，
就五十多岁，
这个正是积极向上的时候，
现在的这个老年人都是，
活力满满，
年轻人目气深沉，
是吧,
他们日子过得好滋润啊，
他说,
不知道，
从哪个维修的师傅那边，
听到讲，
说大众没有怎么减配，
他说,
这个图月，
杰达VS5呢，
自动先锋版，
1.4T动力确实很强，
然后呢，
他有这个后毒律评价，
底盘也更扎实，
内饰虽然是支付座椅，
而且这个标很丑，
但是整体来讲，
它的硬件配备还是可以的，
而这个图月新锐的锐进版呢，
它是1.5升自然吸气发动机，
所以开起来有点肉，
那么底盘呢，
也是扭力粮的候选，
那么再加上三大件的参数，
也不如VS5，
但是这个大众的标，
在我们这个小地方，
它认可度很高，
不用多解释，
这是什么车，
而且呢，
保养也便宜，
用车也省心，
所以就更推荐他，
去买这个图月的行锐锐进版，
他说,
想问问道哥，
这是我给他的推荐，
对吗,
你怎么看这两辆车？
那么,
首先非常的巧，
因为我的BDB你支周五，
更新的视频，
就是大众的图月，
那么这台车，
当年卖到将近20万，
现在降价，
已经是降到入门款，
不到8万，
你没有听错，
那么说白了，
这个车相当于，
它不是减配，
它是降级在卖，
它是把平台，
从原来的MQB A1，
降到了MQB A0，
所以车子相当于是降了一级，
但是大小没有变，
所以这台车子，
特别适合那种，
空间我觉得够用，
然后顶着个大众的标，
然后卖这个坡楼的价格，
是吧,
这就不用都说了嘛，
它应该是目前，
大众的SUV里面，
不知道是不是最低，
反正我觉得，
应该也是非常非常低价格的一个，
非常低入门门槛的一款车了，
所以图约现在卖的非常好，
一个月的销量一万多台，
那么杰达VS5，
我没查它的销量，
我估猜，
它应该连图约的一个零头都卖不到，
而且在我们南京，
好像已经没有什么，
经销商的门店了，
那么四川里面，
我不知道，
经销商的门店，
网店,
多不多，
所以这个也是你要考虑的，
就是今后事后的问题，
你别到时候开着，
开着突然发现，
经销商不在了，
那你今后事后保养，
你保养可以随便保，
但是你要，
万一车子的，
比如说零部件出了点问题，
你肯定还是想回到CS店，
去换原厂的零部件，
同时,
万一要是出一些事故的话，
你肯定是想要去回到，
杰达到CS店去修，
而不是去修理厂去修，
对不对，
虽然讲说，
杰达将来如果没了，
可能大众的CS店，
能够承接杰达用户，
因为他们的配件，
基本上都是可以去供用的，
但是这也很麻烦，
就是往往它的实效性，
包括修车的质量，
它肯定是没有杰达自己的CS店，
更好一点，
是不是，
那么你的这个推荐，
其实已经非常的明了了，
而且你分析的也很清晰了，
我觉得没有任何问题，
推荐它去买图约，
杰达呢，
其实说白了，
因为它标不值钱，
所以它的成本都用在硬件上，
大众呢，
是因为它的标值钱，
所以硬件呢，
配置相对比较拉一点，
那么怎么选，
核心我觉得，
核心是什么，
你要根据人来，
它是55岁刚退休，
对吧,
然后呢，
对手,
刚拿驾照没多久，
它到底在乎什么，
换句话说，
1.4C跟1.5C,。
它能开出差别吗，
你说肉，
它都可能听不懂肉是什么意思，
对不对，
它加效出来的，
它能知道啥，
你说什么多连感，
扭力粮，
它的屁股能感受得出来吗，
它能感受得出来吗，
这种差别，
所以你要知道，
像这种成熟的车型，
像土岳这种成熟的车型，
品控基本上没什么问题，
三连之内，
就算有些东西要换，
你不有质保吗，
那么三连之后，
我说句这个保底的话，
你比方讲说，
你担心将来有问题，
它可能也比较保守，
对不对，
退休了也有退休工资，
可能收入也不低，
让它花个两三千，
三四千块钱，
买个延保不就行了吗，
对不对，
三次店买延保，
有的时候它送保养，
它想把你摔在它的店里面，
保养也可以省了，
然后,
延保还能保它
车上的一些关键零部件，
你就是不买延保，
你将来你出去，
哪个修理场修不了，
如果修理场连大众都修不了，
它可以关门了，
它真的可以关门了，
它连大众都修不了，
它想修什么，
它想修封田，
它要靠封田的话，
它早倒闭了，
是不是，
那么不管是劫达，
还是大众，
我觉得，
你将来不管是在修理场去修，
还是保养，
那配件是遍地都是，
这些是不用担心的，
质量问题，
我觉得，
这种成熟车型，
不用去担心，
然后你自己也讲了，
说四川的县城小地方，
大众的标更值钱，
不用去说话，
车标能帮它表达，
那我估猜你们当地的大众的保有量，
肯定也是非常的大，
肯定是远远大于劫达，
那么劫达这个车呢，
我跟人觉得是，
它不是不能买，
而是如果说，
就是这个50多岁的，
你们家亲戚，
他要是真的说，
已经通过这一年，
把自己修练成，
已经能开出，
柳丽良跟多年感的区别，
1.4T,
跟1.5升的区别，
他就是非常强调自己，
一定要动力好，
他有这种刚须，
让他买接的，
他没有这种刚须，
他说我无所谓，
但我觉得大众挺好看，
他只要淡繁说了一句好看，
让他直接烧卡，
就这么简单，
好吧,
我们再看看下一位听友，
这一位叫做宇田，
他说,
刀哥,
我想找一台R2年上牌，
公里数少一点的，
土睿3.0,
大概我的预算30万左右，
然后网上我看了很多，
但是我担心买到重大的事故车，
请问一下能找你吗，
就你这边有没有好的车源，
好,
我要给你分析一下，
就这个车到底怎么买，
我先讲个题外话，
你叫宇田，
是吧,
我在猜测你的姓氏，
是不是姓雷，
我们南京有一个宇田集团，
他们老板就是姓雷，
所以他把雷字拆开来，
就叫宇田，
公司叫宇田集团，
但是我个人，
其实不建议把你的姓氏拆开，
当然了，
我们相信科学，
我们不相信迷信，
但是我还是建议你去算一刮，
因为什么呢，
因为雷这个字，
雷电,
它是属金和火，
我们讲金木水火土，
雷电属金火，
那么宇田，
它是属水土，
金木水火土，
一个是金火，
一个是水土，
你改完之后，
相当于，
对吧,
属性就变了，
不仅对你自己，
其实对你周围的人，
也会有一些影响，
当然了，
你当我水口一说就可以了，
对吧,
咱们相信科学，
不要去迷信，
那么如果有人知道，
南京的宇田的这家公司，
认识宇田的老板的话，
我相信有些人，
应该就要点头了，
应该你知道这个公司，
这个老板，
他们发生了一些什么事，
对吧,
我们就不具体细讲了，
所以我不建议，
用宇田把雷子拆开，
如果你真的信雷的话，
就不要拆，
如果你不是信雷，
你只是喜欢宇，
喜欢田，
你觉得田园风光很好听，
那没有任何问题，
我水口一说，
相信科学，
不迷信，
那么接下来，
那我们聊一聊，
选车这个问题，
30万预算，
22年的土壤3.0，
那么我估计，
你也看了不少的，
二车行情了，
对吧,
网上,
挂牌价，
基本上，
都在32，33上下，
是不是，
公利数多的，
基本上，
我是网32价格方向者，
那么公利数少的，
车况好的，
那基本上，
都是33万出头，
33万多,
接近34,
那么你让我，
30万,
帮你去找一台3.0T，
而且要公利数少的，
兄弟,
你是不是有点为难我了，
对吧,
我虽然说，
是汽车媒体，
也是个车贩子，
但是,
我也没这个实力，
给你一下子，
砍掉这么多万的，
很透明的，
都很透明的，
而且,
还有一点，
我不是不帮你找，
就是你想想看，
你换位思考想，
土睿,
如果它是一个精品的车况，
那么作为一个车主，
它自己不会在网上，
查行情吗？
哪怕它不懂车，
你想想看，
土睿的车主，
能不懂车吗？
什么人开土睿？
我都不好意思说，
它不懂车，
什么人开土睿，
大多数都是，
玩车懂车的老哥，
他们的这个年龄层次，
一般都是比较高的，
年龄比较大，
好同时层次也比较高，
年龄层次比较高，
玩了很多年的大哥，
这些大哥都不差钱，
他差钱会玩3.0吗？
不会的，
但是他为什么会买土睿，
而且还买个3.0T，
因为他懂车，
他不在乎那个
奥迪的四个环的标，
无所谓，
人家不需要用车标，
证明自己了，
看蛋了，
对吧,
已经可以说上岸了，
财富可能都自由了，
这些大哥，
他觉得开个大众，
就够了，
为什么呀？
因为土睿的底子好呀，
原装进口，
得细血脉，
再加上他本身
确确实实土睿的底子很好，
看起来非常的舒服，
那么谁买3.0T，
天天在市区带布呢？
这些大哥可能都平日不上班，
人家开公司的，
想几点去就几点去，
跑跑业务，
人家不叫跑业务，
人家叫谈生意，
人家买3.0T是为了跑长途，
所以这种车你想要，
找3.0T大排量的，
然后有，
他天天跑长途的，
你还对他有公理数的要求，
这个不现实，
你就找个2.0T的，
你可能能找到一年开一万公里的，
为什么呀，
2.0T的有些人还是牛马，
可能是个管理层，
买个买个土睿，
然后上下班开一开，
低调一点，
但是3.0T的很多都不是牛马了，
这些都是当老板的了，
买3.0就是为了跑长途，
一年开个一两万，
一两万都少，
两三万公里，
所以你想，
二二年的车，
到现在四年了，
你就这样子去，
设想一下嘛，
什么样的用户嘛，
四年了，
他我觉得开个十万公里都正常，
七八万公里便利都是，
你现在在网上，
我相信你看到五六万里都不想买，
是不是，
你想买一个公里数少的，
你要少到什么程度啊，
二二年的车子，
四年了，
五万公里以内，
这个难度有多大，
你自己电量电量，
而且五万公里以内，
你还想三十万左右，
哥们儿，
你觉得现实嘛，
你真的要遇到
这么好的车框的车型，
我为什么要三十万卖给你啊，
我如果真的能二十九万收到的话，
我转手，
我就是批发我三十万，
你把它批给我的同行啊，
我飞了老劲了，
我帮你找辆车，
然后我三十卖给你，
你觉得可能吗，
对不对，
怎么兄弟归兄弟啊，
深意归深意啊，
一码归一码，
是不是这个情况，
如果,
如果我去跟这个大哥去聊这个车子，
好比说车框也很好，
然后二二年的车子公里数，
就两三万公里，
三四万公里，
我跟大哥讲，
我说你二十九万卖不卖，
兄弟,
我要如果被大哥打进医院了，
你能报销我的医药费吗，
那他会觉得说，
你是把我当傻子，
帮我当铠子，
帮我当SB啊，
是不是，
你有没有诚意啊，
你没有诚意不要来看我的车，
浪费我的时间，
是不是，
那你说你为什么不三十万收到这车，
三十万卖给我呢，
我一毛钱不赚啊，
我一毛钱不挣啊，
我是雷锋啊，
我开福利院的，
所以你这个需求，
我真的很难满足，
所以呢，
我建议你是这样的，
小红书发发铁，
什么咸鱼发发铁，
虽然说有可能，
你也找不到，
你大哥也不可能上咸鱼去看车，
对吧，去卖车，
那你就找一找吧，
反正就求贵有缘人嘛，
对不对，
求贵有缘人嘛，
好的东西，
永远是稀缺的，
我的个人建议就是，
你要精品车况，
然后呢，
公利数少，
你要这种，
就是需求，
非常非常明确的，
二二连左右的，
那你就多掏点钱，
就买个安心就可以了，
我觉得就算你花个，
三十二三十三，
你也不亏啊，
这个车子，
保持率还可以的，
它绝对值这个价，
啊,
你遇到公利数少的，
车况好的，
又是个大众土锐，
人家保养的那么好，
对不对，
你多花点钱又怎样的，
是吧,
好,
我们再看看下一位，
听有啊，
这一位叫做小五，
他说,
大哥,
我最近想给家里面的老人，
去换一辆纯电的新能源车，
预算十到十五万，
我看了，
零跑C10,
深蓝S05,
INI-60,
和银和E5这几款车，
那么现在比较倾向于C10，
那我想问这款车质量过不过关，
而且我听说这个车要换代了，
所以我比较纠结，
希望刀哥给个建议，
我经常看到这种问题啊，
我就特别想，
怎么讲呢，
我就想去，
喷一两句，
你给家里的老人换车，
看来看去都是按照你的意愿，
你问过老人的意愿吗，
老人想开电车吗，
老人天天愿意去外面，
去在那个充电商上充电吗，
老花眼，
你充电可以玩手机，
他老人充电在旁边，
跟个呆子一样的，
他拿个手机，
老花眼，
手机离老远的，
他能干嘛呢，
你让老人充电的时候，
他回家，
腿脚也卖不动了，
给老人换车，
听老人的建议，
老人说我想开游车，
你就给他买游车，
老人想开增尘或者是插混，
你就给他买，
这个增尘插混，
你为什么要买电车呢，
全部都是按照你的想法去，
你作为年轻人，
这车子，
你是有支架，
有什么发295的车机，
有这个有那个的，
他会玩这些东西吗，
所以给家里面老人换车，
什么给老人换车，
你就是给自己换车嘛，
说白了，
真的我都不想讲了，
你说410这个车，
到底怎样，
410这个车没有问题，
平民电车嘛，
对吧,
办家理想嘛，
主打性价比嘛，
空间大配置高，
造型也不难看，
这个车我也试驾过，
你要如果说有什么问题，
其实没什么大问题，
主要就是这台车子的轮胎，
我觉得是比较省成本，
它配备比较低一点，
整车的隔音也比较一般，
所以这个车在高速的状态下，
车内的胎高跟路噪是偏大的，
那其他的都没啥问题，
电车开起来也很轻松啊，
但是我觉得，
你要如果真想买，
带着老人去跑一段高速，
去感受一下，
一个是驾乘的这个感受，
第二个就是车内的精密性，
你把速度尽量拉到100以上，
如果说销售价，
我上不了高速，
你至少也得是绕尘吧，
绕尘跑个80，
压着80,
85左右你去开，
感受一下精密性，
是不是能接受，
那么质量问题还好吧，
反正我到今天为止，
我天天去报导一些新闻，
我也没看到有什么人，
大面积的投诉，
如果是他有共性的问题，
像我们作为汽车媒体，
应该是能看到的，
没有,
那么都是一些小问题，
你比方说什么，
刹车意想啊，
雨刮漆刮不干净啊，
窗户的深降有意想啊，
还有什么大灯起雾啊，
这些都是有一些
概率性偶发性的，
那我觉得这个车能不能买呢，
能买啊没问题啊，
为什么不能买啊，
销量也不差，
而且就算有些小问题，
它制保器你该修修嘛，
该换换嘛，
是不是，
你要担心过制保，
买颜保嘛，
这个车子，
我觉得就是你要担心，
一定要买颜保，
它跟油车不一样，
油车的话，
如果将来有些什么配件坏了，
你到外面去修，
去换都没问题，
但是电车有很多的修理厂，
它不太敢去修它，
所以这就是跟油车。
最大的差别，
那么回到前面我讲的，
你给老人买车，
你给他折腾那么多干嘛呢，
老人买车，
老人就要审刑，
这个车子就老老实实开，
就可以了，
买个什么封铁，
买个什么大众，
十两万块钱，
对不对，
你加油它也不是加不起，
老年人退休金，
比我们年轻人还高，
是不是，
你为什么要考虑
这些电车给它呢，
我就始终想不通这一点，
还要说，
要不要等换代，
等换代两个问题，
第一,
这老人换车，
它能等得及吗，
现在都不知道
什么时候给它换，
对不对，
第二，就算换了，
换来换去，
无非,
要么就是，
续航长一点，
什么充电速度快一点，
要么就是，
什么车机芯片换好一点，
哪一点对它是刚需，
我请问，
所以说，
等来等去，
等得都是你自己的一些想法，
你把它当成一个
电子产品去买，
但是对于老人来讲，
它就是个逮捕工具，
它要买的是逮捕工具，
你要买的是个移动家具，
移动的家用电器，
所以以后，
能不能尊重一下
老人的意见，
什么,
你付的给钱就行了，
少在旁边逼逼，
好吧,
我们再看看，
下一位挺有，
这位叫做木头人，
他说,
哎，哈喽，道哥，
我想在上海买，
未来的ET5G，
我报你三刀的名字，
能不能比店里面，
更优惠一点，
能不能更优惠一点，
我是一个小主播，
你当我是谁，
你当我是，
李斌的亲弟弟，
还是咋的，
这不是我们家开的，
你报我名字，
就能滴了吗，
我且不说，
未来是不是一口价，
你太看得起我了，
就算这个未来，
是有一家的空间，
就算这个销售认识我，
你报我名字，
也没用，
为什么没用呢，
有人讲说，
你三刀不是天天带人买车吗，
好，我告诉你，
带人买车，
和你报我名字，
是两码事，
你报我名字，
很简单的道理，
你跟他销售讲，
你说，我认识三刀，
销售怎么回呢，
如果他情商高一点，
他比较说，
你也是三刀粉丝，
也许巧了，
他真好就是我粉丝，
我也是，
对吧,
我也是三刀粉丝了，
当兄弟了，
都开始聊的家常了，
三刀最近播了一期节目，
三刀在西马拉，
这个节目，
最近七天不能更新了，
对对对，
我也知道为止，
里面聊得很开心，
好,
大家都是自己人，
我告诉你，
到了自己人，
你谈钱，
就很麻烦了，
真的,
他会跟你讲说，
我家和其实，
给的很有诚意了，
兄弟,
真的很有诚意了，
我甚至可以给你看，
其他人的订单，
非常非常低了，
你怎么办，
哥马尔达是三刀粉丝，
你帮我再跟领导申请一下吧，
好,
他转个头，
出去,
他可能去抽根烟，
就回来了，
他说,
兄弟,
我跟你讲，
巧了,
我们领导也是三刀粉丝，
你看,
都是我粉丝，
领导说了，
今天给你这个价，
就非常到位了，
你还不能告诉别人，
我再给你，
让你,
一千块钱，
我或者再送你一个两次保养，
人家已经给你，
这叫发盘跟还盘，
人家给你还盘了，
这个时候你怎么办，
你不相信，
你不相信他，
你不相信三刀，
对吧,
我是拿着三刀的面子，
给你换了这两次保养，
给你换了一两千块钱，
你现在还是不满意，
那你就是不给三刀面子吗，
好,
请问你现在订还是不订，
这个价格你订不订，
你说他行，
这价格我订了，
好，你订了，
你也是卖我面子是吧，
你订了，
订了之后，
你回家想了想，
可能旁边，
媳妇插了两句嘴，
哎呦,
你提什么三刀，
三刀的面子也不值钱吗，
我觉得，
你价格是不是买贵了，
好,
一个人讲，
然后你妈在旁边也在讲，
对不对，
然后你叔你姨也在讲，
说哎呦，
那天我在，
哎呦,
我在那个，
我们同事聊天的时候，
说什么，
未来能优惠三四万啊，
那个又，
过来讲了半天，
你最后就开始心里面，
就有点，
有点低估了，
你说是不是真的买贵了，
好,
你再换一家店去问，
或者打个电话，
去外地去一问，
一问,
太高了，
你到我们店来能更便宜，
我请问，
当你听到这个的时候，
你怎么样，
你会骂我，
你肯定会骂我，
你说妈，
包三刀的面子，
一点屁用都没有吗，
他把我给宰了，
三刀的粉丝，
对吧,
他也是我粉丝，
联合起来把你给宰了，
其实你这个价格，
有可能在你们城市，
就是最低的，
但是你拿着这个价格，
再去问，
我告诉你，
永远是下一家店，
就是最低，
或者下一家店更便宜，
一个城市最便宜的价格，
你拿着我的价格，
一家一家店的去问，
你问到最后，
你绝对不会感谢我的，
你只会觉得说，
包我，名字没有用，
三刀这个面子都掉地上，
都碎了一地了，
而且你会觉得说，
就算你成交了，
就算你拿的价格低了，
你也会认为，
这不是我的功劳，
这是因为你会砍价，
你的价格砍得很到位了，
有人讲说，
那三刀，
你还帮人去买车吗，
那你是怎么帮人买车的呢，
我告诉你，
我从来不让人去店里面，
包我的名字，
我是老兄弟，
十几二十年多兄弟，
我都不会让你去包我名字，
你包我名字吃亏的是你自己，
你先不要包我名字，
你把你浑身的，
能谈价格的本事，
全部使出来，
使劲的砍，
砍到最后，
就连哭傻子都砍完了，
就价格一点都弹不下来了，
你爱走就走了，
销售也不拉里了，
你可以跟他讲，
你说这个价格，
我回家考虑一晚上，
我考虑一晚上，
回家之后，
第二天白天，
一定要是白天，
因为白天工作时间，
盾牌才能回复你，
你去加微信，
46415254,。
很多我们老亭友，
都有这个微信，对吧，
你跟盾牌联系，
盾牌会给你发一个，
我们给你预设好的，
一个小的，
像表格一样，
就是文字嘛，
你填好，你不要写麻烦，
你要如果连填这个东西，
你都写麻烦，
你不要来找我，
我本来带人买车，
也不挣钱，
你把这个表填完，
发给盾牌，
盾牌立马会转给我，
我马上就把这个相关的，
你问到的最低的底价，
不只是一个价格，
包括你有没有消费的项目，
SASD也没有赠送你的项目，
你拿到哪些补贴，
你把补贴的金额，
也全部要写进去，
那么我会通过内部的渠道，
我会帮你去问，
总经理，
销耳总监，
区域经理，
我会帮你去问对口的这个人，
这个价格合不合适，
那么如果他说，
这个价格不合适，
他们的店，
会比这个价格更便宜，
OK,
我马上，
开始发给他，
你们直接一对一的交流，
诶,
你已经谈不下来了，
这家店的价格比你家更便宜，
那你为什么不找他买呢，
如果是同城呢，
你就直接同城买，
如果不是同城呢，
你去电量一下，
一地买合不合适，
对吧,
省下来几千块钱，
你就当旅游了，
你愿不愿意，
那你不愿意，
你还在当地买，
但是你心里面有底了，
那如果说你的价格，
我带你问了一下，
发现诶，
你的价格很低，
很合适，
你直接定就行了，
我只是帮你去做一个监督，
做一个过滤嘛，
是不是，
就这么简单一件事，
我只帮你做最后的灵门一脚，
所以这就是我的买摆车的业务，
也做了十两年了嘛，
找三刀买摆车，
那就是填个表嘛，
填表都不愿意，
就不要来找我了，
而且不要上来就问我，
这车最低多少钱，
我不可能是作为一个，
什么报价的机器，
我今天给你报个价，
明天给他报个价，
你要知道，
每一轮报价，
它都是有时间成本的，
这个报价不是我张口就来的，
是背后正二八经是，
发了消息出去，
然后问了人，
然后等对方回复消息，
回完消息之后，
我要帮你去过一下，
是到底合适还是不合适，
合适你们俩就对接，
不合适你就自己买，
那有人要做那图什么呢，
我图什么很简单，
当我有大量的，
询价的信息的时候，
这个叫销售线索，
那么经销商会觉得说，
三刀这边也很牛呗，
你做媒体，
你还有真正的粉丝，
来找你买车，
那么我跟他们去借试下车，
就会非常的方便，
他们甚至于，
会主动把试下车交给我，
所以现在各种南京的，
各个品牌，
4S店,
够关系都非常的好，
为什么，
就是因为，
兄弟们经常找我询价，
找我询价呢，
我会跟他们去过一遍，
过一遍他们经常也说，
做不了，做不了，
价格很低，价格很低，
那价格很低，
我就告诉你，
我帮你找的是电总，
我帮你找的是销售总监，
人家也不会去忽悠我，
价格非常合适，
那如果能成交，
我也帮他们促成了好几单，
每个月都有，
不止好几单啊，
就是每个月都有，
可能几十单，
上百单肯定是没有的，
十几单，几十单肯定是有的，
所以各家4S店就很喜欢我，
那么因此他们跟区域，
也会去讲，
说三刀，
人家不是，
跟其他的汽车自媒体一样，
只是什么，
集结广告啊，
出去牛皮衣什么的，
三刀是真的是，
给我们店里面，
导销售线索的，
你会觉得说，
三刀这么厉害吗？
他不但是做媒体的内容，
他还有那么多的粉丝，
找他买车，
那么他们也会去，
再跟厂家，
往上一层去汇报，
跟大区总，
或者是跟总部去汇报，
那么总部一听说，
这次媒体有点东西，
很多自媒体都是假流量，
都是刷出来的，
三刀这边，
不但能做内容，
还能去带货卖车，
厉害厉害，
我在找三刀区做合作，
我赚的是广告费，
我赚大家的这个什么，
卖个车，
赚个叉价三刮俩，
早的这个钱，
还不如我一条广告，
还不知道能赚多少叉价呢，
你说是不是，
所以说白了，
我的逻辑就是，
还是就广告，
做商业，
就像你们说的充值，
但是呢，
音频播割这个地方，
大家就把能客观的去聊，
对吧,
那后面，
我们就是把握好尺度，
有些时候尺度把握不好，
就节目就不能更新了，
那么同时，
如果需要找我买车，
那就联系盾牌，
微信4641,
5254,
或者直接上我的知识星球，
对吧,
你也可以提问，
你也可以跟我交流，
因为我都在嘛，
知识星球我每天都会上嘛，
然后同时你真的要找我，
你最后我就告诉我，
好,
帮我寻个价，
就行了，
那么以上呢，
就是本期节目所有的内容，
改拿收听啊，
那么由于一些特殊的原因，
我的节目在喜马拉雅那一头呢，
暂时无法更新，
一直是到，
24号解禁啊，
那么18号跟22号两期节目呢，
就暂时不做那个，
就是前一期节目的留言互动了，
这个抽奖的机会呢，
我们就延续，
那么,
15号,
就是上一期，
18号,
今天这一期和下一期，
22号,
三期节目，
那么我们回头，
在25号,
周六更新的那个节目里面，
就三期一起抽，
行啊,
那么以上就是，
本期节目所有的内容，
大家如果想关注我，
其他的平台的话，
那么我有微博，
摆车全说三刀，
还有我的长视频，
在bilibili,。
大家可以搜索摆车全说，
还有就是短视频平台，
在抖音视频号，
小红书，
快手,
摆车,
那么还有就是，
我的公众号，
摆车全说，
每天都有更新，
大家可以去关注一下，
想要联系我们，
下回请，
4615254,。
今天这期节目就到这里，
我们下一期，
接着聊，
拜拜!